I look at it as phenomenal because AI is
gonna do [ __ ] that below average humans
do poorly
[Laughter]
you got your prospectus
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
by being patient I mean the slug should
live under their roof you're playing by
their rules so they're stop taking their
money and move out and then you live on
your own whether they're 17 or 23 or
just be patient and appreciate their
opinions but in their own life and don't
require them to do anything like your
parents and many people's panics you
bring a ton of value and I feel like a
lot of people continue to ask them to do
more
I just don't ask like their life
[Music]
that you inspire people all over the
world every day across multiple channels
online I'm going to ask me inspires you
both in and in the past little optimism
optimism inspires me people who have
very little who have severe challenges
and persevere maybe this is where I'm so
affected by my mother my mother lost her
mother when she was five she grew up in
the depths of Soviet communist Russia
her father went to jail for a decade
she's know something as a person I know
when people come up to me and like oh I
have it so I'm like I was just think
about my mom
you know she's so positive so optimistic
and she had such [ __ ] as a child you
know Carrie I don't want to end on it
down right but you want to talk about
how people real quick I don't think what
I just said about my mom is a downer and
I think it's an interesting insight
I actually think adversity is the great
gift in our society and I think that if
you really look at who's upset for real
it's the people that grew up entitled
and are then zoo animals when they go
into society because they were so /
coddled not the ones that have chips on
their shoulders
and had a lot of negativity no man
that's in five minutes
god I'm so nervous today's the NBA
lottery and there's an incredible
basketball put in college Zion who
everybody wants and the jet that the
Jets the Knicks are one of the teams in
the running to get the ping-pong ball
it's a big day the other dunk everybody
it's the pelicans the Grizzlies the
Lakers in the Knicks that's the top
court
so coming back on commercial Lakers got
it
what's that I know we do let's go
Cheers
all right I'll be right back the third
pick goes to the New York Knicks no
third third god dammit god dammit
[Music]
the pelicans got it
no more pick pelicans
this was 1985 there 0% chance of one of
those teams yep hi guys thank you
thank you the Knicks didn't get Zion so
I'm dead
so energy is gonna be down at least one
solid notch you know one thing I really
am passionate about that's evolved for
me and I'm thankful for it is I try not
to talk about [ __ ] that I don't know so
the answer is I'm not sure I haven't
done enough homework
on AI to answer that thoughtfully like
the other questions I think it's
inevitable the technology is inevitable
but I think people grossly underestimate
human beings like we evolved into other
[ __ ]
I think AI is gonna do a lot of dumb
[ __ ] that we shouldn't be doing anyway
and and it's going to be impactful but
not the way like I don't think this I
think this could be a precursor to the
robots killing us which I do think is
inevitable I think we'll miss it
thank God but I think our grandkids
might be [ __ ] you know but I think
what a AI is gonna do is and and if
you're talking about an arms race
between China and the US if you're
talking about humans vs. robots like
technology eliminates commodity and I
think AI is gonna eliminate a lot of
things that don't bring value in 2026
and I think those humans will find other
things to do
listen I got you know for a lot of
personal thank you so much a lot of you
do follow me a lot of you know I was a
really bad student and I love always
posting my ridiculously bad report card
but there's one really interesting
insight that I hope helps everybody here
the besides Jim the one class that I did
well in was history and I've only now
started to understand why I basically
use history very heavily to decide
what's gonna happen next
like everybody who's talking about AI is
so bad and so like all this like these
articles were written about machinery
around farming we just knew that we were
all farming we went on to do other [ __ ]
like we're gonna do other [ __ ] and by
the way like I don't feel bad for a
truck driver
who isn't reading headlines for 20 years
that autonomous trucks are coming
we gave him 20 [ __ ] years like when
they cry in 2039 like oh the [ __ ]
autonomous trucks took me out I'm like
did you had 20 years you couldn't have
learned another skill along the way
[ __ ] I need this and I see celery
clapping listen listen I'm unbelievably
like I have a lot of different thoughts
but I will say this we are living in the
golden era of entitlement and like the
quicker you can get entitlement out of
your body the better and so yeah like
technology happens I'd much rather be
dealing with the pre-dawn days of AI
then dealing with the Black Plague that
happened to humans they live during a
time where everybody almost [ __ ] died
so like you know like we complain about
dumb [ __ ] you know like the Holocaust is
recent like [ __ ] happens like I'm not
worried about [ __ ] AI meaning yes a
lot of stuff will happen but I don't
view it as this negative arms race I
look at it as phenomenal because AI is
gonna do [ __ ] that below average humans
do poorly
[Laughter]
which and and I this is where it's
really interesting to hear that sentence
carefully
it makes me then think that that human
could actually then go do something that
they do like and do well that's not like
you suck human you should know it's not
something like rogue [ __ ] it's actually
understanding how humans work which is
when you find something you like and
you're good at it
life is a lot better than when you don't
or when you just chase money or when you
dwell that the system's against you I
like the pressure of Technology I think
it leads to a lot of happiness for a lot
of people who can just look at the other
side of the coin my friends
you find what you're looking for in life
you want to think everything's negative
and [ __ ] you can find that all day as
you know but if you want to think
there's a ton of opportunity and this is
the greatest era to be alive you can
find that too because the math supports
it pick all right head of the airport
back to LAX then Singapore you're
amazing the gentleman's room no I'm good
okay I got a virgil's for you in your
bag thank you so much almost as good as
still almost sort of an agency and I'm
just trying to think of how to actually
like prioritize what I'm doing with work
I just graduated last week how to
prioritize like what I'm doing with my
job and then what
by building a framework of patience like
if you think you need it tomorrow you're
gonna burn out and you're gonna put too
much pressure on yourself
by realizing that I was working a cash
register when I was 27 years old like by
really understanding that like you can
easily do it if you cut out leisure if
you want it so bad you can do it but
it's gonna take you twenty six months to
make that jump not next week and I think
once once you have a framework of
patience then you can pull it off and I
think where everybody gets caught is it
everybody wants it so fast that it [ __ ]
them up does that make sense yeah like
if you literally said okay if at 26
which means you as [ __ ] I'm gonna happen
right exactly
I did the math of like it's especially
if you said to yourself at 26 I'm gonna
have my own agency now all of a sudden
if you know if you're tired one night
because the job or if your buddies want
to go and watch the Game seven of the
NBA Finals now you're not so frantic
that you have to have your [ __ ]
agency in six months dude I've been
telling people I'm gonna buy the Jets
when I'm 70 since I was 15 you can
imagine why that's made it easy people
give it on the jet set somebody said
today in six months carry me I'm like no
I'm not I don't do that take some of the
pressure away real you know that will
really help you Ryan like it really will
do you know what I mean because then
it's not about being frantic and manic
every night like all of a sudden you're
not beating yourself up on one night
where he's just gonna [ __ ] play
fortnight and drink a beer because
you're thinking in 50-year terms not in
50 day terms there's a lot of there's a
lot of time bro and if as long as you
realize you want to build this for
yourself not to prove to everybody look
at you know then you can they get slow
when it's for yourself and your patient
everything goes slow and you got a real
shot
take care of a welcome